docteur couach bonsoir comment
allez-vous danseurs mais ça va merci et
vous très bien très bien alors vous me
l'aviez déjà dit mais vous êtes non
seulement aux gets à l'aise avec la
rouverture lundi mais fallait faire ça
pour le bien-être des enfants
oui tout à fait je pense que quand on
regarde les avantages et les
inconvénients de la réouverture des
écoles c'est sûr qu'il ya un enjeu où on
peut se dire est-ce qu'il va y avoir
plus de transmissions de decaux vide
dans les éléments qu'on a besoin de
tenir en compte c'est que les enfants
sont plus malades et que par ailleurs je
pense qu'il y en a déjà pas mal qui ont
fait la queue vide mais que d'un point
de vue scolarisation réussite scolaire
développement socialisation ils sont
bien plus heureux à l'école que derrière
leurs tablettes ou les écrans
d'ordinateur docteur boileau tout à
l'heure est donc là on attend depuis
plusieurs jours les gens dire ce n'est
pas comme la coved de du delta c'est
différent et on doit donc ajuster nos
protocoles de retour quand quelqu'un a
eu la copie dans une classe on ne doit
plus fermés toute la classe les gens qui
ont été en contact peuvent retourner à
l'école seront pas de symptômes et après
cinq jours la personne malade doit peu
revenu ça ça vous semble raisonnable
aussi de d'assouplir tout ce protocole
qui était quand même assez lourds
mais je pense que comme ce qu'on voit
présentement c'est que le micron est
quand même 50 % moins virulent que le
delta que encore une fois le les enfants
se portent bien avec l'aco vide qui en a
beaucoup là-dedans qui sont même
asymptomatiques c'est à se dire que
quand il ya déjà un cas dans la classe
même si on on fermer la classe dont les
retirer tous il ya déjà eu une certaine
contagion c'est un peu comme avec la
varicelle ou je sais pas si vous vous
rappelez quand on était jeunes on
faisait la varicelle on nous retirait de
la classe pendant une semaine on avait
le droit à une semaine de congé à la
maison mais aujourd'hui les appelons la
varicelle iris à l'école parce que comme
la transmission s'est déjà fait avant
l'apparition des boutons n'est plus
vraiment davantage à retirer l'enfant
par la suite donc c'est un peu cette
réflexion-là le qu'il faut faire et
aussi parce qu'éventuellement il va
falloir apprendre à vivre avec ce virus
là il est là pour rester sous une forme
ou sous une autre et compte tenu de tout
ce et du besoin que ces enfants là on
d'être à l'école je pense que les
décisions sont bien prises votre
collègue dr weiss hier 10 à cette
émission
pas se servait beaucoup dans des
questions qu'on a le genre dans un autre
champ de votre expertise la vaccination
ils le disent eux qui ont fait la
contracter la maladie et qui sont
adéquatement vaccinés qui ont déjà de
12,2 vous précipitez pas nécessairement
pour la 3è d'autres pouvaient attendre
un peu d'autant que de nouveaux vaccins
qui vont arriver pour les enfants qui
ont eu une première dose donc pardon de
8 ans 9 ans 10 ans quand une première
dose et qui ont fait la coved après
est-ce que vous êtes vous du même avis
qu'il est préférable d'attendre un peu
pour la deuxième dose pour les enfants
en fait ce qu'on dit toujours c'est
quand on vient de faire l'infection
notre système immunitaire est à son
maximum on est protégés contre le virus
convient de combattre et donc ils
peuvent vraiment davantage à aller
chercher la vaccination tout de suite je
voudrais que l'enjeu un peu plus
logistique ou organisationnelles c'est
de savoir est ce que notre enfant a fait
la coved ou pas parce qu'avant noël vont
ça allait là la plupart des enfants qui
avaient fait la coved avait un pcr
positif ou avait un contact direct avec
un pcr positif sauf que depuis une
semaine et demie ça devient hyper
difficile de confirmer la réfection et
donc on n'est pas trop surtout notre
enfant était un peu malade est ce que
c'était la coved un autre virus et c'est
dans ce contexte là où on se dit bon si
on le sait pas il n'y a pas vraiment de
danger à aller chercher notre donne au
deuxième dose alors qu'elle était prévue
mais si on a une confirmation c'était
bel et bien la coved par pcr on peut
absolument attendre quatre à huit
semaines avant d'aller chercher la dose
de rappel bon et puis pour les plus
vieux
pour la troisième dose où j'ai touché
d'accord avec dr weill
ya pas de précipitation à y avoir non
plus pour l'a3 l'a12 je rappelle qu'on
est adulé on a fait la coved
absolument en fait la décision du comité
d'organisation du québec c'était ça
c'était de dire que quand on avait eu
deux vaccins est une infection la
troisième dose était pas nécessaire mais
si jamais on goulet idéalement on
attendait deux mois après l'infection
avant d'aller la chercher mais on
comprend encore une fois ça veut pas
dire que toutes les copies dont été
confirmée saveurs des gens accèdent et
est et c'est dans ce contexte là où le
gouvernement décide et 10 rebonds mais
pour des raisons d'équité si vous n'êtes
pas trop sûr vous pouvez quand même allé
la chercher à la fin de vos symptômes a
fait ce que je comprends que c'est pour
des raisons de communication aussi de
simplicité comme vous dites que le
gouvernement dit vous allez y pour la 3è
dos parce qu'il n'ya pas non plus de
danger à se faire vacciner le troisième
dont on a eu la coved c'est juste que
vous dites c'est inutile vous êtes déjà
protégés
exact c'est inutile on est très bien
protégé en fait l'infection protège de
façon beaucoup plus large donc une dose
de vaccin est habituellement la
protection suite à l'infection dure plus
longtemps qu'une dose de vaccin donc
tout ça mis ensemble aucun bénéfice
direct aller chercher une 3e dose quand
on vient de faire le coup du bon je
pense est clair clair clair très bien
est ce que vous voyez les graphiques
est-ce que vous aussi quand vous vous
étudiez vous voyez qu'on est arrivé aux
fameuses semelles de cette courbe
c'est sûr que de compter les infections
ça devient très difficile parce que
encore une fois - accès déteste quand on
regarde il a l'air de s'aplatir il va
falloir voir si les hospitalisations la
courbe des hospitalisations s'aplatit
aussi je pense que ça va être notre
meilleur indicateur mais dans
différentes juridictions dans le nord
est des états unis aussi on voit qu'il
semble y avoir un ralentissement de
l'augmentation des hospitalisations et
des cas et donc ça je pense que c'est de
bon augure ça fait un mois qu'on est un
mois et demi à peu près le conte est là
dedans et donc on devrait comment on
devrait peut être pas loin du plateau et
l'immunité collective on n'a pas loin
mais comme beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui
l'ont qui ont contracté la coved ça aide
par ailleurs oui c'est sûr c'est sûr que
ça aide parce qu'à ce moment là
et on a mis des espèces de murs de
protection entre les gens qui sont
encore à risque et donc plus on aura ces
grandes îles de protection - il va y
avoir de transmission communautaire donc
on espère qu'on va arriver à une espèce
de protection à tout le moins partiel ce
qui est plus difficile dont le savons et
le mitron et c'est que le micron qui se
transmet donc que c'est facile mais les
gens qui avaient fait de l'infection
dans le passé où les gens qui avaient eu
deux doses de vaccination même s'il
avait une protection partielle on
empêchait pas complètement les
infections donc on empêcherait pas non
plus complètement la transmission et
donc ils les gens les plus à risque donc
les personnes plus âgées avec des
conditions médicales sous jacente
demeurer à risque d'avoir une si jeune
mais la trappe et d'avoir une qu'ovide
plus compliqué donc le vraiment le
message c'est aller chercher votre dose
l'eau vous êtes rendus dans votre
protocole si vous n'avez pas encore été
vaccinés faites vous vacciner on le sait
le que même à deux doses on a une
excellente protection contre les
complications et pour ceux qui sont
admissibles à la dose de rappel vinci
temps d'y aller aussi docteur couach
merci beaucoup encore une fois au revoir
merci bonne fin de journée